vamos a hacer la parte del problema de
la papa y dice usan la segunda derivada
de h con respecto al tiempo para
determinar si la respuesta del inciso am
es una sobreestimación o una
subestimación de la temperatura interna
de la papa en el tiempo te igual a 3 así
que recuerda en la parte am encontramos
la ecuación de la recta tangente que era
esta que tengo aquí en el tiempo de
igual a cero y lo que hicimos fue usarla
para estimar el valor de la temperatura
interna de la papa en el tiempo de igual
a 3 ahora como es que la segunda
derivada nos va a ayudar a saber si ese
valor era sobreestimado o subestimado 20
igual a 3 bueno es que la segunda
derivada nos ayuda a conocer la
concavidad es decir podemos saber si la
pendiente de la recta tangente de
nuestra curva está creciendo o está
decreciendo y podemos usar esa
información para saber si estamos
sobreestimando o subestimando
este valor así que qué te parece si
primero calculamos la segunda derivada y
para eso voy a traer por acá a la
primera derivada déjame ponerla por aquí
y bueno vamos a buscar la segunda
derivada ahora lo que me doy cuenta es
que de aquí puedo distribuir este menos
un cuarto es decir esto es exactamente
lo mismo que la derivada de h con
respecto al tiempo ok de bueno de menos
un cuarto
d h ok de hdt más o menos por menos es
más
veintisiete cuartos ok y ahora hay que
derivar esta expresión observa lo único
que hice fue multiplicar menos un cuarto
tanto por esto como por esto ok ahora sí
vamos a encontrar la segunda derivada y
la segunda derivada de h
ok
con respecto al tiempo ambas veces
va a ser igual y bueno hay que derivar
esta expresión que tengo aquí y ahora
vamos a derivar este primer término con
respecto a tema es decir me va a quedar
la derivada de menos un cuarto de h con
respecto a tema que va a ser la derivada
de menos un cuarto de h con respecto a h
lo cual es simplemente menos un cuarto
menos un cuarto ok que va a multiplicar
a la derivada de h
recuerdan es una función de t a la
derivada de h con respecto a tiempo lo
cual es simplemente la derivada de h con
respecto a t
esto es simplemente aplicar la regla de
la cadena esto sale de la regla de la
cadena y después tengo la derivada de
una constante con respecto a t bueno
simplemente es cero así que no voy a
escribir nada aquí y ahora que nos está
diciendo todo esto
como vimos en el vídeo anterior si nos
preocupamos por este intervalo en el
cual t es más grande que 0 entonces
puedes verlo aquí en la gráfica la
temperatura interna de la papa siempre
va a ser más grande que 27 observa eso
quiere decir que esta expresión que
tengo aquí esto que tengo aquí va a ser
siempre mayor o igual a 0 porque un
número que es más grande que 27 menos 27
es un número positivo pero después al
multiplicarlo por este menos un cuarto
voy a obtener un valor negativo así que
algo positivo por algo negativo me va a
dar algo negativo y entonces puedo decir
que tanto esto de aquí o bueno está de
aquí los cuales son iguales ambas déjame
ponerlo está y está son negativas déjame
ponerlo así como h es más grande que 27
de mayor que 0 ok entonces esto quiere
decir que la derivada de h con respecto
a t
es negativa ok y ahora también podemos
decir que como
como ya sabemos que esta derivada es
negativa como la derivada de h con
respecto a t es negativa para todas t
mayor que 0 para
mayor que 0 entonces la segunda derivada
de h
con respecto a ti ok
esta va a ser positiva porque observa
tengo algo negativo que está x algo
negativo y me da algo positivo entonces
algo negativo por algo negativo me da
algo positivo para todas t mayor que 0
para t mayor que es 0 ok y esto qué
significa bueno si mi segunda derivada
es positiva esto quiere decir que
tenemos una concavidad hacia arriba así
que déjame poner una concavidad hacia
arriba lo que quiere decir que nuestra
pendiente está creciendo nuestra
pendiente
y está creciendo o lo que es lo mismo
nuestra pendiente es cada vez menos
negativa así que vamos a escribirlo
también nuestra pendiente es menos
negativa y bueno qué significa todo esto
lo podemos ver aquí como la pendiente de
mi recta tangente se hace cada vez menos
y menos y menos negativa entonces para
nuestra aproximación para t igual a 3
usamos una recta con una pendiente muy
negativa cuando en realidad nuestra
pendiente de la recta tangente es cada
vez menos y menos y menos negativa es
decir que lo que hicimos en esta
aproximación pues sobre decrecer la
temperatura de t igual a cero igual a
tres lo que significa que subestimamos
en nuestra aproximación así que déjame
ponerlo esto implica
ok
subestimamos en el inciso y si
estuviéramos en el examen ap intentaría
expresar mi respuesta de una manera más
clara pero espero que para ustedes esto
tenga sentido en el siguiente vídeo
vamos a resolver la parte sep y última